hi everyone my name is Steve Dawa I'm an
engineer at Microsoft I work on the
Python tooling in Visual Studio that
were about to show today I'm also a core
C Python developer and one of the
windows experts so I'm heavily involved
in that had a lot to do with the changes
in 3/5 for better or worse today what
I'm going to do is we're going to take a
bit of a whirlwind tour through Visual
Studio now just before I get started so
I've got some context how many Visual
Studio users are in the room Python or
not any language great you guys are
going to hopefully learn one or two new
things but there's a good chance that
you've seen all of this before because
you're in that visual studio environment
which I'm sure you know and love for
people who haven't used Visual Studio
this is the one tool where you get to
live and do all of your Python get to do
all of your C++ whatever other languages
you do Web Design is all available in
there it's the one tool that you get to
live in and stop thinking about
switching between 17 different tools or
however you approach it so what I aim to
show and you can follow along if you
like there's enough detail in the slides
that you should be able to do that feel
free to wave your hand and make me slow
down if you're trying to keep up I'm
more than happy to do that everyone
who's not following along can use that
opportunity for questions or just to
generally relax and slow down from the
hectic pace of the conference but we're
going to go through a range of things
that you get from Visual Studio and when
you move from the really disintegrated
17 different tools workflow into having
an integrated environment some of the
benefits of that and just the niceness
that's all together and the aim for
today I'm going to build this in fact
I've already built half of this what
this is is a map of the solar system on
a particular date and I have some nice
little controls here I can advance month
by month fingers crossed for Wi-Fi there
we go it's still working and each month
and I can pick an arbitrary date and
it's going to calculate the layout of
the planets in here so there's two
components to this the first one is a
basic website written in
neighthan which we're not going to look
at I did that individual studio took me
a couple of hours it's fairly basic it
looks like a developer audit and I stole
the images from somewhere who've arey
kindly did not put horrible licenses on
them but the back-end service is the
thing that we're going to build so the
front of this is a really basic website
that calls into a micro service that
calculates the locations of the planets
on a particular date and that's the bit
we're going to do so we're using a
preview feature of the Azure machine
learning studio which you may or may not
be familiar with I'll touch on that a
bit more later but it's a preview
feature that lets you take just an
arbitrary Python function and say
publish this to the cloud and give me an
endpoint and you do that and suddenly
you have this rest endpoint to call your
Python function and get the results back
and that's running in the cloud it's got
a full anaconda disrobe behind it so you
can use pandas you can use non-pay
whatever one-off calculations you want
to do in the cloud you have access to
whatever data you need back there as
well let you do like let you really
quickly publish and that that will
happen within the hour
assuming the Wi-Fi holds up publish a
micro service that gives you a simple
Python function that you can call
so I'm going to start with Visual Studio
and the first thing that I need to do is
get the source code so I'm not going to
code it all by hand right now the source
code is coming from github so this is
the site and in fact I should have that
is the site for those following along
again fingers crossed on Wi-Fi this is
publicly available feel free to take it
play with it do it if you like improve
the the website part of it and send pull
request for that I'm more than happy to
take any designer contributions there
but this code is on github it's not set
up for Visual Studio yet it is a pile of
Python code that someone maybe someone's
been working on a different machine
entirely someone's been working on Mac
on Linux
they've just dumped the Python files
there and now I want to pick them up and
start working with them in Visual Studio
the first step is getting the code into
Visual Studio and before you go and
reach for forget on the command line
there's a number of other options the
first one is we have a nice big button
down here that says open in Visual
Studio with Visual Studio 2015
Community Edition while all editions
there's a github extension and the first
time you sign into that through visuals
to your github flicks a switch on your
account and any repo you go to will have
this open and visual studio button there
so it's now one click to get from the
repo in github into Visual Studio with
that code I'm not going to do that I'm
going to copy the URL to the clipboard
and jump back to visual studio I already
have team explorer open team Explorer is
the hub for working with other people so
depending on the system you plugged into
Visual Studio online github another git
repo another team foundation repository
this is where you access source code new
commits you can do all your branching
and merging and get syncing work items
whatever collaboration you need runs
through team Explorer
and right now I'm just going to clone an
arbitrary git repository which is the
one that I copy pasted and just hit
clean I do have a backup for this if
Wi-Fi bills and this is all integrated
into Visual Studio we don't install the
get tools behind it we've had our
engineers contributing to Lib get to for
a couple of years now really making that
work nicely on Windows personally I find
the git command line completely
impenetrable I'm very much a mercurial
guy but with the visual studio support
for it I can actually use it and so now
I have a repository here by double click
through that now I get a set of all the
things I can do we know it's based on
github so a handful of these are going
to link directly to github and just open
the site so poor request for example
will jump straight to the page but I can
view branches and remotes locally I can
view history and get a graphical
representation of what my history looks
like and all of the syncing branching
and merging rebasing which which
honestly even with this I still can't
make rebasing work okay can be done from
here so there's barely a need to jump to
the command line forget anymore it's and
if there is then you're in more trouble
than you know I'm very sorry if you need
to go to the command line forget at this
point but we don't have any code visible
yet which honestly I'm very sad about
and I'm working hard to fix but we have
a directory full of code and we can't
see the code right now the current way
we have to to suck in all the code
Visual Studio is based on projects for
those who aren't familiar with it it
doesn't the the directory basically
saying here's my directory this is where
my project is doesn't fit the model that
Visual Studio has been using for 10,000
years or so it's based on project so you
have a file that says that lists the
files that are part of your project and
that lets you that lets you more easily
deal with noise files so P YC s never
show up
in your project because you don't add
them generated code doesn't show up in
your project because you don't add it
it's effectively a list of things that
you would want to check into source
control because we've just checked out a
source control I need to make a new
project and what we've added for Python
because this comes up all the time is a
tool to import from existing Python code
that says from existing Python code I
can't read that from here so I assume no
one else can and this will jump you into
a wizard because we've come out of this
repo that we just checked out all the
settings are actually really good so I'm
just going to hit finish
and this will generate a Python project
with all of the code in
but as you work with project files and
especially since no one else on any
other platform uses them they're going
to get out of date which is an
unfortunate thing it's saying that we
are working on but it's the nature of a
project file this this has a list of the
files that I care about when someone
else on another platform adds a file and
checks it in that doesn't show up in my
project
so when things do change we we have a
button up here called show all files
that's going to add in that's that's
going to bring in everything that's
currently in that directory
this can get noisy especially in Python
code suddenly you've got pyc files
showing up everywhere but it does let
you do nice tricks like saying all of
these views for that website should be
included in the project I actually want
those and I can right-click and include
in project and now they're in and if I
come to a directory that I don't want
like this entire website I can
right-click and exclude from project and
now it's out and after I've done
catching things up to date then I can
turn that off again and I've got an
up-to-date project that's an unfortunate
fact of life right now we have our
fingers crossed that we can fix that
completely in the next version which is
some time away yet but that is how it
goes one of the nice things when it's in
the project source control is integrated
the whole way through so if I now jump
over to any of these files and start
renaming adding or deleting things it's
going to update git for me so it's
already there it's tracked automatically
or attracts the deletion all my changes
will just go through but the whole
reason we're here is for editing code so
let's look at the editor let's hide that
for now you'll notice syntax
highlighting that's standard if we
didn't have that then you'd have you'd
have every right to get up and walk out
right now an editor comes with syntax
highlighting we take that a little
further and do really deep code analysis
so if you use the visual studio then
you're fully aware that you get
completions for when you start typing
things so I can start importing modules
and get the full list of modules
available as I dot through those I'm
going to get a list of everything that's
available in that module and we've done
type inference the whole way through
Python standard library and all of your
code so as you're passing variables
around or passing values around we track
the types of that which means we know
what type everything is at
any point and you can see date time here
we know as a class we know it's a type
so it's highlighted in a different color
and even if I alias that then you'll see
that we flow that through and we know
that DT is the type now as well and so
we give that the same color and we'll do
that for functions will do that for
parameters functions are currently
colored black so you can't tell but it's
fully customizable you can choose
whichever color you like is going to
help you best understand and read the
code that you've got in front of you we
also have collapsible blocks if you've
used c-sharp you will have seen hash
region before and we made that work for
Python because people kept asking for it
but you can also collapse dictionaries
functions if blocks basically anything
that takes up more than one line of code
you can collapse to get it out of your
way and focus on the stuff that actually
matters right now you'll see here a
green squiggly line which is letting me
know that there's a module that's
unavailable so I'm trying to import and
use this module we couldn't find it so
we're just letting you know quietly it's
not going to stop you running Python
there's a lot of ways to resolve modules
at runtime that we can't do from an
editor without actually running
arbitrary code on your machine without
asking you so we'll give you that will
give you that warning and give you an
opportunity to fix that there's some
workarounds that we have to tell the
editor without affecting running code
and there should be syntax errors but
apparently everything's good to do so
where are those gone now that's what's
happened okay we also have this neat
window called the Python environments
window for managing multiple pipe and
installations for people on Windows this
is really common our our own statistics
that we've collected from users show
that on average people on Windows or
visual studio users on Windows using
Python have three or more so they
typically thread two and a half three or
more Python interpreters installed at
any one time and so being able to manage
them is really important so we have all
of them expose I have a lot because I'm
a
we have them all exposed through this
window and will let you easily jump to
where they are start executing them
whatever you need to do with it let's
not pick that one we also have a concept
of the default which is why the syntax
errors weren't there because now my
default is Python 35 and I have red
squigglies everywhere I've used print as
a statement it's not it's not much but
it's nice to have that warning up front
that the code you just opened is not
going to work under your current
settings there's something wrong with it
and we'll do this for a lot of parser
errors
we're very gentle about things that may
be errors that may not so we're not
violent as an option you can run pilant
but we're not doing it for you because
there's just so many places that we can
be wrong getting to that you preempted
me by about five seconds so so I grabbed
some code off github and it's missing
packages how do I know which packages
it's missing Oh someone's left a
requirement start text file in that that
says these are the packages you need
which is basically implying that I need
a virtual environment the syntax errors
here are letting me know this is Python
- sorry Bret but unfortunately the
preview service were publishing -
currently only supports Python - so I'm
working in Python - today so I need a
virtual environment and I need some
packages over in solution Explorer so
that window I had before with all the
Python environments was global settings
those are available everywhere -
everything virtual environments we treat
as part of the project so when you make
a project you can give that a virtual
environment and manage that just for
that project and then it stays separated
from any other project you have open so
it's we've we've really chosen that
workflow that people use and strongly
encourage that you can set up a virtual
environment and have multiple different
projects use it and I see enough looks
of disgust from the audience that
you're right that's not a good idea if
you really want to do that it's possible
we don't recommend it and so we don't
make it real easy but what we do make
easy is creating a new virtual
environment for this project so I'll
right click this Python environments
node and just add a virtual environment
very simple wizard here I can choose the
name which I don't want to change I can
choose the version of Python it's based
on which is going to be 2 7 64 bit and
it's already found the requirement start
text for me and tick the box that says
go off and download and install these
packages so when I hit create it's just
going to start working this is not doing
anything magical we're shelling out to
the tools in the background if you don't
have virtual land and you run this it's
going to install it for you
and in fact it looks like it upgraded it
for me which is very nice if you don't
have pip we're going to install pip so
we can install those packages we're not
doing anything new and magical we are
just using the tools that are out there
there is some basic condo support once
you're in a condor environment or we
don't have any support there to create
it but for the continuum employees in
the room this is a public extensibility
point and if you would like to add condo
support you're more than welcome to do
that we're happy to give you info on how
to do that if you if you haven't got
sorry if you don't have the text file
then there are currently two ways to
manage packages individually because
we're migrating from one to the other
currently they're both available so over
here we can see I now have the virtual
environment with the list of packages
installed I can right-click this and say
install Python package and get again a
simple dialogue that will let me choose
pip easy install or condor if it's there
and then I can simply finish off the
command-line and install whatever
package it is I'm looking for the other
way is back in this Python environments
window this overview drop down will has
a pip view which will show me what's
currently installed in pip it will give
me the versions it will let me know that
there's updates available and so if I
wanted to update setup tools that's one
click away to the newest for
and as I search it will give me the
option of simply running the command
line I know that's unreadable I'm sorry
the first one says pip install whatever
I just typed so if you want to add extra
options you can just add extra options
and do whatever you need the rest of it
is search results from pipe yeah so it
says install Asha install as your batch
apps install as your blur I don't know
who wrote as your blur actually that's
not one of ours but I have to have a
look at that and then just clicking on
any of those is going to install that
package and if you don't have pip
installed this entire window just has a
big button saying install pip and then
we have some magic to install pip but
after that we're very keen to just keep
using the standard tools if you install
something from the command line which I
can very easily do I can right click on
the project open command prompt here and
now I'm in a command window and it's
actually set up to use the virtual
environment so I can wear Python I can
wear pip and it will show me that the
ones in the virtual environment are
already set up to use so just pipe in
this pip install whatever and then that
will just show up inside Visual Studio
as if you installed it through here so
it's it's very loose coupling with the
existing tooling so we want you to keep
using the existing tooling but at the
same time any point where you need to
switch out of Visual Studio is a failure
because we haven't fully integrated your
development environment and so we're
always looking for ways to say oh people
need to switch out here to do this how
do we bring that in so they don't need
to be jumping around from place to place
okay now that that
than that apparently I don't have web
browser
and this is where the demo all goes
wrong it's okay another thing I just
quickly did you can have more than one
Python environment attached to a project
so if you want to support Python 2 and
python 3 at the same time you can have
them both in there and just easily
switch between them it's just a right
click activate and now I've activated
that virtual environment for my project
I don't understand why that
apparently I'm having some other issue
that I don't fully understand right now
oh okay
one unfortunate thing this is going to
take a while
that type inference I mentioned on the
Python standard library we run that in
the background because it takes a while
there's a lot to the Python standard
library full type inference of the sort
that like my pain a whole lot of tools
are coming out try and do we do it does
take a little while and until it's
completed we can't give you intellisense
which is just an unfortunate side-effect
of the way the whole system is
architected underneath so what we should
be seeing here is those green screens
Quigley's go away but they're not
because we're working really hard in the
background to get rid of them
apparently I installed something that I
shouldn't have right before a demo and
now it's taking a lot longer to refresh
but everything is installed and it's
there so we can move on now that I've
grabbed this code what I want to do
first is run the tests and make sure
that everything's still good so we have
unit test integration just for the basic
unit test module we don't currently have
anything clever for knows or pay tests
or anything like that but if unit tests
discover is going to find the tests then
we will also find the tests and when you
hit run will go through and run them
again using unit tests
one less reason to jump out of the IDE
yes so the easiest way to say run the
script to run my test so so yes there is
because there is a way to say run this
script so indirectly there's
unfortunately no way to say run the
script and transfer the results into
this nice-looking window is the
limitation but you can absolutely so I
can jump to this test and I can
right-click anywhere in the window and
say start with or without debugging and
that has not set up the paths correctly
so it didn't work but that's if that is
the approach that you want to use for
running your tests then that's a totally
fine approach to take no no there's
currently tests need to be run
sequentially but you can you can make
less do the smaller selection so I can
grab a handful and say just run these
tests and don't run all of them there's
various groupings so I'm currently
grouping by treats for whatever reason I
can group by by class and choose just
the tests in that class to run I can
group by outcome so I don't need to see
the ones that passed I'm only interested
in the ones that failed so now I want to
see why this one failed because this is
interesting and this is where we get
into one of the coolest things about
Visual Studio that it brings to your
Python experience because you can jump
around for all the tools that we've seen
so far but it's very hard to jump
anywhere that's going to give you a
really good debugging experience so I'm
picking up this test that just failed
and I'm going to first set a breakpoint
in the test and now just hit the bug on
the test you'll see a bit of flickering
but in a couple of seconds we're going
to pop back into the editor and we'll
have a nice yellow line on the
breakpoint that I accidentally said
before
and we'll say a nice yellow line on the
line of the test where I set the
breakpoint
and now we're here I have a really cool
interactive debugging experience as I
said before if you've used Visual Studio
for other languages you're totally
unimpressed right now because we do this
for all of them so if you're using C++
you get this for using c-sharp you get
this using VB you get this using
JavaScript you get this using nodejs you
can have this but we have it for Python
as well and so from here we're in a test
that says there's testing all the
planets like I said back at the start we
have a micro service that calculates the
locations of the planets on a certain
day so here's that day which I believe
was the day I did the last demo so it's
not quite as applicable today but what
I'm going to do is step in so there's a
void shortcuts for all of this but I'm
clicking on buttons for the sake of the
video and now I'm in this function I can
hover over any variable apologies for
the small font size but I can hover over
any variable and see the value that's
currently there these are expandable
where where it's appropriate
so this mercury global variable I can
expand you can see we have big arrays of
values that I can expand into and all
that various information I can even make
changes and stuff so if I don't like the
Year 2015 here I can change the value of
that and now I'm working with a
different value in that variable so it's
an interactive experience I get to
control when we move to the next step
next line of code I get to inspect and
change if I like the values of any
variables at any point and soon I'll get
to see where the errors are so I can
step over that and now T is the date
time as they keep stepping you can see
we keep executing more code the autos
window is automatically showing me all
the variables that are nearby where I am
question
change what you referenced so change
just change no so changing variables
changes the locals it's exactly the same
as an assignment statement would be so
if you hit year equals 2012 then
changing it manually to 2012 has exactly
the same implications as that and
eventually when I step out of this
function I now have the result so I have
this big dictionary of all the results
from calling the function which again is
completely unreadable on that screen I
apologize and now I as I step through
the tests we're going to see that most
of these are passing we're checking for
the where the planets are and it broke
out at that point because we hit one
that failed so the one that failed was
Pluto if I look at the output from the
test then again completely unreadable
but it's fine if you up nice and close
to the screen assertion error Pluto not
found in the list of planets that we
returned I I look I'm very sad about
that but in its defense the dataset that
you use to calculate the locations of
the planets known as the vsop87 the
eighty-seven means the data set came
about like was released in 1987 and at
that point they did not include Pluto so
so what the internet discovered fairly
recently the Astronomy world appears to
have known for a much longer time or at
least back in the late 80s they believed
that Pluto is not a planet so
unfortunately that means the test is
wrong here and we should not be checking
for Pluto and now when I go and rerun
this test we should see that there are
no two other problems with that one and
it will disappear and moved into the
past test section so I don't have to
think about it we've got a nice green
bar the second test this one is failing
with a value error and it's fairly
obvious in this case where it is but I'm
going to pretend that it's not
the way I want to diagnose this is to
bring up exception settings this dialog
lets you control how the debugger reacts
when certain exceptions are thrown and
so what I'm interested in here is
catching that value error as soon as it
occurs so I'll put in a search just to
narrow it down and tick that box so now
when our Python code throws a value
error it's going to break into the
debugger immediately it doesn't do the
trace back all the way to the top of the
program and then say oh yeah this is
what was happening back when the
exception was thrown it's going to stop
immediately I can inspect the state
exactly as it is I can keep stepping as
we go out frame by frame and really get
a good view of what led to the state
that caused the exception to be thrown
so now that said I'm going to start
debugging this test and when that value
error is actually throwing you'll see
that we break in right at that line
where the value error occurred day is
out of range for month 2015 this year
month to February day 29 not the right
day to choose and so we have an issue
here jumping back up to the test did I
mention the coalsack window the call
stack window shows the call stack so all
the calls that have been made and will
let you jump back up so you can inspect
any of the locals in any call frame so
far so you don't have to rely on tracing
back through the code and go oh this
parameter was this argument which came
from here which came from here you can
actually jump up to the frame and see
the parameter where it's being passed in
you can make changes there that's going
to probably confuse you more than
anything else if you aren't working in
the topmost frame but you can jump
around and now I've jumped into the test
infrastructure which is going to get
messy but we can see here from the test
that an invalid date should return a
complete set of planets but all zeros
for the coordinates this is not an
example of good spec writing because I
should not be writing the spec as a
comment in the test but it happens to be
where I knew I was going to end up in
the demo so it works well question sorry
yes you can run as many or as few tests
as you like it's all about which ones
have been selected from the test window
which which I can stop debugging now so
hit stop and in test explorer I can
control click as many tests as I like
and just run those so knowing now that
we have a contract of sorts to fulfill
we should go in and handle this value
error and in fact you'll see that this
is a to do comment so I should have been
doing this anyway but there's a nice
easy way that we have integrated here
slight aside under the View menu there's
a window note called the task list and
this task list
is automatically searching all of your
code and anywhere you have a comment
that starts with to do it's putting it
in the list and it's doing the same
thing for hack it's doing the same thing
for undone or bug and it's completely
customizable so there's a set of options
that you can change to add more tags
that you want to automatically add into
your task list and so the Python source
base for example would have xxx Nick
Coughlin for all the places where he's
undone stuff so we can find the things
we need to fix hi Nick he's not watching
so not directly this is though I do
believe it used to an earlier versions
but no okay
okay I I believe it does in the
Enterprise Edition of Visual Studio so
I'm running Community Edition I can't
see it here I believe there is some
integration to the task list for tasks I
honestly have not used it so sorry so we
have a task we need to handle this value
error I could just start typing because
we are just going to use an exception
block what I'm actually going to do is
use a code snippet so this is a nice
little shortcut that Visual Studio
provides for inserting code and there's
two choices you either insert a code
snippet and keep typing or you can
surround with so I've selected the code
that we need to protect and under edit
intellisense I have these two menu
options insert snippets around with you
can when you navigate through the menu
you'll see the keyboard shortcuts for it
I'm going to choose surround with and
choose to surround it with a try block
and so I've just inserted that code and
now I can add in the value error that I
want to handle and and add the handling
for that these these shortcuts are
actually much simpler to just insert I
can type tray and hit tab to get the
rest of the block completed I can do the
same thing with class to get a class
definition created functions and these
are extensible you can write your own
ones of these
this project the the Python tooling for
Visual Studio accepts contributions and
we would love to have people come and
say hey I made this cool snippet would
you guys like to include it we're more
than happy to accept those contributions
rather that they as well as people
wanting to get deep and dirty with all
the c-sharp code running behind this if
that's not to your liking then anything
that makes code snippets more useful for
people and in fact you're especially
interested in django stuff so if you
have django code snippets that you just
keep using over and over again we'd love
you to say hey here's a django you know
here's my five django code snippets
would you like to include them because
the answer is yes but now I need to
handle this value error since I have to
return a full dictionary of all the
planets but with the same but with an
empty value I'm just going to copy and
paste that and let's fix up indentation
and now I have the fun job of going
through and typing 0.00 a lot which I'm
not going to do I'm going to hit ctrl H
which brings up Find and Replace and now
I'm going to hit this little button here
that enables regular expressions because
you'll see that we have there's a common
pattern here there's the name of the
planet dot position at T that I just
want to replace all of that and so I can
start typing the regular expression
we'll see all the matches within the
current selection and now I've just
selected all the bits of code that I
need to replace and that's the result
replace all and it's done that one
didn't make it into the slides so you
only get that if you're actually
watching this so now when I go back and
run that test it's returning the
expected value and so it passes and now
we have completely passing tests we'd at
this point I would probably jump back to
team Explorer and go to changes make the
commits probably exclude the
project because the rest of my team
doesn't necessarily want that and I can
recreate it whenever I need to make the
commit and then go back to sink and
either push a new branch and send a pull
request from that or if I'm lazy just
push directly to the main repo the other
to do that we had on the task list a bit
of refactoring work so like I said the
whole point of this is to publish a
function to a micro service which
unfortunately needs a bit of boilerplate
code to do that so I've written that
because I was not going to write this
live but it's all just been written
under the if if name equals main looking
through it this is fairly generic code
there's there's only one sort of real
parameter to it this function that we
pass in that we want to publish and
otherwise the rest of it could be reused
for a different function so so I do want
to refactor this separately to do that
I'm going to grab all of this code
except for the press ENTER and under
edit refactor you'll find extract method
again there's a keyboard shortcut there
depending on the settings you've chosen
that shortcut will vary for me it's
control our control them but this will
let me take that code and extract it
into its own method this gives you the
option of choosing the scope so if
you're within a function you can choose
to extract it to the module level or
still within the class and there's all
the nesting is handled so this drop-down
that only has module scope in it will
have all the levels of nesting you have
so if you have if you're defining a
class inside a function you can extract
the method into the class or into the
function or into the module it's
anywhere you want to put it you can put
it I'll call this do publish and you'll
see there's a preview here of how the
code is going to look watch this section
here see well there's empty parens we're
not passing any parameters in because
we're closing over all the variables
from the outer scope which are listed
here get all planets is that function we
don't actually want to
is over that we want that to be a
parameter so that to make this function
reusable we want to be able to pass in a
different function to publish next time
so unselect that and now we have that as
a parameter so get all planets is going
to be passed in as a parameter they hit
OK and we extract the method we keep the
scope consistent by returning all the
outside variables which we don't need so
I'm going to delete the returns but now
we have a function standalone separate
function totally collapsible if you
don't want to look at it and the only
thing wrong with it is our generic
parameter which is any function we want
to publish is called get all planets
which we don't really want we want to
make this a generic function name so I
can right click and choose rename and
we'll call this function this is
different from find replace find replace
is going to find everywhere that I've
written get all planets and change the
word to say function which is not going
to be correct I only want to change it
in the context of this bit of code and
so when I preview the results you'll see
that that's exactly what rename does
we're going to change here from get all
planets to function the parameter name
and then the place where we use it in
this function we'll rename it as well
from get all planets to function but the
other location so where we've passed it
in has not been changed where we defined
it has not been changed
that will look through the entire code
base that's in your project this is
where the projects concept becomes
important if the file is in your project
then we'll find all the references
throughout your project so if and in
fact I can show you that because get all
planets is referenced in a number of
places now and so I can change this to
get all planets except Pluto and preview
the changes and you'll see we've found
the one that's in profile test we've
found the current the places we're using
it here we found the places we're
calling it in the tests and I can choose
to not change some of them or I can hit
a play and now they've all been updated
something I missed before is if you when
you're in the test and looking at the
function you're looking at the use of
the function you probably want to see
the function itself and so you can right
click and say go to definition or it's
just f12 convenient shortcut and that
will jump you directly to where the
functions defined this also works on a
significant portion of the standard
library but not OS da path do I have
anything that I can use web browser I
can navigate to web browser in the
standard library because we've got that
mapped back to the name so if you have a
library that you're looking at that you
need to read the full documentation most
of the time f12 is going to take you
straight to the original doc string and
let you scroll around copy/paste
whatever you want to do with it so great
points can be set so okay the question
is can you set breakpoints inside we
refer to it as standard library modules
that also includes anything you've
installed into side packages and the
answer is yes there is an option to
enable it though so by default you can
set breakpoints wherever you like and if
we're not tracking the code at that
point you'll never hit it and so we have
an option tools options Python tools
debugging
which is enable debugging of the Python
standard library when that box is
selected then we're going to go through
the entire standard library as it goes
so if you have a breakpoint there you'll
hit it you can step you can inspect
variables if you're not interested in
debugging the standard library then
having this unselected will make
debugging faster in general because it
does slow things down to be tracking
everything and so when this is
unselected by default you'll get a
slightly faster experience in most cases
but if you do need to debug inside an
installed module
I believe setup top paid develop modules
will debug by default I don't think
those are included then that option is
there if you need it speaking of how
fast things go
we should profile this function just to
find out what the hot spots are I'm not
going to fix anything right now I have
this module which I've just called
profile test very basic script that just
exercises it we go through a range of
dates and we just call the function we
don't do anything with it the whole
point is to call it enough times to get
some interesting results in the
profiling data and I'm going to analyze
and launch Python profiling I can choose
all the options I like here so profile
whatever I like whether it's a project
or not in this case I have an open
project that's already set up that I
know is working out run all the tests
and so I can just start profiling and
this is going to go through run the code
whatever interactions I have set up
ideally for profiling I've taken those
out as much as possible
and when that's complete we get a nice
report that can take some time to
analyze but lets you navigate through
all the profiling results you can see
the call tree you'll get percentages of
how much time is spent in various places
you have the ability to jump through
jump from function to to like from
caller to call a jump back to the
original source and you get
the hot spot so the hottest spot gets
marked right for you the hot path this
court ad function we're spending a lot
of time I can jump through I can see the
function here I can see that a lot of
the time is in math cosine which I can't
do much too much to fix but this is
probably the point where I say oh I need
num pay to do this for me I shouldn't be
doing it in pure Python code or maybe I
just reach for number and see if that
helps
which should I expect it probably will
in this case to optimize that but it's a
really simple way to just get those
results and again in the interest of
using the existing tools this is based
on C profile so we're not injecting any
proprietary magic into here the magic is
we take the C profile results and make
them browsable all right so I've reached
the point where I get to actually
publish the service last time when I did
this demo this is where basically
everyone dropped off and I don't think
anyone's actually following along so
it's not a big deal but this is so to be
to be clear and complete disclosure this
is a preview feature of Azure machine
learning studio if you haven't seen as
machine learning you can browse to it
there is a free go and play around with
this what this is is Microsoft's sort of
managed platform for doing machine
learning so we provide a lot of the
primitives and when I say primitives I
mean sort of fairly high level machine
learning primitives in a simple
drag-and-drop
configuration screen which is not to
everyone's taste but it is very useful
for a lot of people who are sort of
higher-level like getting into things as
opposed to people that have been working
with Python and scikit-learn from
directly for a long time we also have a
publishable web services out of this
which lets you take your data do
whatever training and testing you
want to do on that and publish it as a
consumable and an importantly sellable
service for other people so you get a
web api out of your data that you've
trained a model on and you can then sell
that model you can sell access to that
model to other people so it's for
example a a webstore may come to this
service and say I would like to
recommend a service I don't want to
figure out recommendations myself I want
a recommender service based on someone's
data set they won't give me the data set
but they will let me access their
endpoint to make a request and say you
know I have this person here's the last
five things they bought what should I
recommend them next and there's a
service there that will do that based on
someone's existing data set and the
important thing there is if you put up
that data set and that model you're you
you get to charge a couple of cents or
however much you choose to charge for
someone else accessing that service so
it's a really easy way to take an
existing data set that you have or an
existing model that you've trained
something that you've designed and
worked on and actually make some money
off it and not just have not just either
have to keep it secret because it's too
valuable or give it all away and not
have any way to either recoup the costs
that went into producing it or even just
to live off it
the other really cool thing which I may
get to a little bit later on
if you go through this service and click
through that get started button and
click on the guest access button you get
eight hours free and then you can click
a new button and go to the notebook
section and spin up dripping the
notebooks online which is again a
preview service that we're working on
but it is going to be the enterprise
ready
Drupal a notebook hosted service I'll
show that a little bit later on
assuming I get the time
so to do all of that which I'm not going
to go through its it is in the slides
there's some logging into a workspace
I've got to get some access tokens in
fact I am going have to do that because
otherwise I can't demo the publishing so
I'm going to sign in hopefully this will
work
so the notebooks for those who are
wondering new notebook path and three
paths and two we have a welcome we have
more samples coming right now I need to
grab some information about my workspace
so I can publish to it I'll be switching
back and forth so apologies for the
flashing the workspace ID is how we
identify this oh ok so the pipe and
micro service I mentioned you can take
any you know ml this service that you've
made and publishes a web service the
Python is exactly the same thing
we take your arbitrary piping code and
publish that as a service and it's still
in preview there's no marketplace setup
for that just yet
but you can take your arbitrary Python
code push it up to these servers that
are built for massive scale the idea is
that people can be hitting these servers
with requests from all over the place
that you can be reselling these and so
publishing your arbitrary Python code to
that is actually a really cool
lightweight way of getting there so I'm
just running the publish script I don't
need that workspace IDE goes in I need
an authorization token which I'm going
to have to regenerate after this and
apparently this is not going to work on
the internet in this building yes I yeah
I'm not doing that on screen so
pretending that all succeeded this this
is actually one that I prepared earlier
there is not much left to the demo after
this point publishing the service takes
us back to exactly the starting point
that decided from what I would have been
doing and what you can do when when you
do this from your own home the top level
of this website which is linked from the
slides has a space to copy in the source
in the API key that's generated for your
service and so then you can be using
this front-end website with your own
back-end service and be generating this
map from the micro service that you just
published based on
small amount of Python code so that's
the high level of what I had to cover
I'm do a lot of these demos though and
I've covered basically everything in the
product at various times does anyone
have any requests because I'm happy to
show you anything in the product yes
glad you asked that because you saved my
plant from asking that so the answer is
yes this is one of the unique features
of it's not there this is one of the
unique features of Visual Studio that we
get to be able to do because we have
support from multiple languages in
Visual Studio so being a multilingual
IDE you can not only can you use Python
C++ C sharp
whatever languages you can use them all
at the same time so what I'm opening up
here is a sample solution that has two
projects in it one is a Python project
it's called super slow code it has some
basic benchmarks in there for
calculating 10h over was it 10 million
values and putting it into a list and so
I can run that and there's no way you
can read that I'm sorry but it's going
to take about six seconds oh two seconds
that got fast oh okay last time I did
this I was using Python 3 for I now I'm
using Python 3 5 last time it took 6
seconds on the same machine if you're
considering moving to Python 3 5 I think
I have a good reason for you to do that
I actually have no idea to be honest
there's some optimization at some point
but the code that we're doing here is
this plain old Python code that
is iterating through ice light it's a
nice slice over a callable iterator and
it's just calling a couple of Python
functions on it doing some floating
point math and adding it to a list so
possibly the memory allocator on the
list improved because this is a million
elements but generally I have no
explanation
I should profile that though I did not
expect that bigger jump but I can get an
even bigger jump because alongside this
super slow code that is no that is now
just moderately slow code I have a C++
project called super fast code and all
I've done here and there's a video of
this online if you go a KMSP TV s
tutorial we have a playlist on YouTube
you can also probably to search for it
where I walk through a whole lot of this
stuff and then demonstrate this in one
of the later videos this code is
basically identical to the Python code
I've done no magic here to speed it up
apart from doing a straight translation
into C 10 H was a little bit more work
because I'm now dealing with the the
Python API so I have a conversion from
double to double and then back from
double and the rest of this is again
much the same code we're iterating
through a sequence doing a calculation
adding it to a list the two projects
have a reference between them so if I if
I clean the solution you'll see that
this super fast code module doesn't
exist it's got the green squiggly line
it's referenced from this project all I
have to do is hit build and in fact I
can hit run and if it needs to rebuild
it will automatically rebuild the C++
code and now that's the squiggle has
gone away we know it's there we have the
doc string for the function that we're
calling I don't think we can have 12
into it nope
and I can now run third benchmark
using the C code which is down to 0.7
seconds which is not quite the order of
magnitude it used to be but before any
continuum employees asked I have not
tested with number but I'd expect it to
be faster because I've made no effort to
optimize this but the question is what
happens when things go wrong what
happens when you get an error and I've
obviously done with this before because
my usual error is gone there's a benefit
of an ad e right you could accidentally
have an if statement without a closing
brace and not notice that you've added
something that's outside the if
statement until you hit semicolon and it
fixes the indentation for you and now
it's obvious that you've made an error
and a security vulnerability but for now
I don't have that so now when I start
running
that's the magic before the screen and
in fact this thing is already configured
nope okay so for everyone who missed
that error that said you returned from a
C function without setting an exception
if I run that again there we go so in
the regular Python debugger default
settings this is the area you get
exception pops up says hey this function
returns null without setting an error
there's something wrong so what we want
to do is be stepping through it to find
out what that problem is exactly but
being a plain pipe from the bugger if I
just set a breakpoint here and run and
keep stepping we're never actually going
to hit it because we're going to we're
not going to step into that function
we're just going to step over it because
again pure Python is based on set trace
set trace doesn't work inside C
extensions nobody who's dealt with C
extensions is surprised but over in the
properties for the Python project we
have this neat little check
box it says enable native code debugging
so if you come here and check this box
and now when I hit f5 to start debugging
we launch the debugger in a different
mode so it's not pure Python anymore
it's a hybrid which does mean that there
are some things that don't work that did
work in the pure Python one but now
there's some other things that work that
didn't work before so I can still hover
over variables and see their values
there's more cases now where we can't
edit the values simply because we're in
a different mode but as I step this time
when I step into the fast map 10h
function I've actually jumped into the C
code and now as I'm stepping through
here we'll see oh this I was not meant
to hit this line that is clearly where
the error is I can hover over a result
and see that is not null we should not
be failing I can expand it we have a
Python view here which is one of the
neat things we add because if you've
ever debugged pipe that like pythons see
implementations it's really really
painful you can so so what we add when
you're in this mode is the Python view
which is not interesting yet because
this is an empty list I'm just going to
skip the line and keep going as I step
over so I've just appended an entry to
result which you can't tell from looking
at the high-level description which is
all you get in a regular c debugger with
our extension i will go to this window
instead of using the mouse when i expand
it I get a Python view and this Python
view shows me how it would be
represented in Python so it's a list
with a number in it so we can see the
list with the number and if I set a
breakpoint here and just keep hitting f5
will see another number show up and the
list is going to keep growing each time
I step through eventually it's going to
get to the point where it changes to say
this is a list of length 12 because
there's no point showing you all the
numbers but I can expand that out and
see each entry of it
right there so when you have mixed sea
in Python code you can absolutely debug
it you can build it you can develop it
together in Visual Studio we have a
template that I really need to get
around to releasing that makes building
a C extension for Python 3 5 really
really easy
the reason it's really easy for 3 5 is
because we changed 3 5 to make it really
easy so unfortunately it doesn't work
well for earlier versions but it works
great for Python 3 5 I can spin up a new
extension build it into bulk mode build
it release mode build a 32-bit build at
64-bit all the the cross-product of
everything that you need on Windows at
least for a reliable and reusable C
extension you can you can get the other
thing that we changed in 3.5 over the
earlier versions is if you're using
Visual Studio 2015 you have the right
compiler earlier versions you need to go
back in time a long time because there
aren't even downloads or the compilers
that well okay so there's a download of
the compiler that you need for Python
2.7 which you can find online but
there's no IDE integration for that
compiler anymore unless you go back in
time and find it so 5 and 3.5 is really
smooth experience now for building
through Visual Studio when I release
that template if you'd like that
template you're a visual studio user
just come up to me afterwards and I'll
give it to you it's just a small handful
of files but I'll get that online
probably on probably on my github
sometime soon so keep an eye on that and
I'll post it there yes
my son
yes so there are yeah okay so the
question is is there a way in Visual
Studio to to have the debugger break
based on some programmatic conditions so
it's not every time you hit a certain
line it breaks it's only if something
happens to be set in a particular way so
there's two ways of doing this the the
quick and easy way is when you set a
breakpoint you'll notice this little
thing pop up with a Settings button this
lets you add conditions so I can make a
breakpoint conditional simply by
specifying what the condition is so if I
only want to break here when it ER
equals no put up I can do that and now I
have a conditional expression on the
breakpoint so the break point is not
going to stop if we hit it and that
condition is false but when that
condition is true then we'll stop at
that point there's also an option for
hit count so I can choose to only break
on this the tenth time we hit that break
point so the first nine times are just
going to go straight through 10th time
we hit it we stop and so if you know
that something doesn't become a problem
until the 999,999 time you hit it you
don't have to sit there hitting continue
for a long time and keeping count unless
you really want to and this this has the
option for a greater than is multiple of
if something's a problem every fifth
time you hit it you can say every fifth
time we hit this break and otherwise it
will just keep going the other way of
doing it which has some performance
implications but requires you to
recompile is there is a command called
debug break and when that function is
called it's going to break into a
debugger so you don't ship with that if
you ship with that your users are going
to get very upset because they're going
to get pop-ups saying this program is
crashed we're sending information to
Microsoft about it if they have a
debugger it's going to say you should
attach to this with the debugger and
they're going to go I don't know how to
fix this but if you have some really
complicated condition that you want to
break on and you
and change the code and insert it this
is going to perform somewhat better yes
so syntax highlighting and let's jump
back to the Python code the the options
for this are under tools options fonts
and colors and things can be scattered
around a bit there's a few options here
that are global to visual studio that
are shared so things like comments are
going to appear under comment and that's
all of the comment colors in visuals
here including Python keyword
I think identifier is in there as well
number so if you want to change the
color of numbers to bright pink then you
change that in number and now all my
numbers are bright pink and that also
applies in C++ as well because it's one
global setting there are some that are
specific to Python and so if you scroll
down this list to the where they start
being named with Python then you have
you can choose different colors for the
built-ins so I think at the moment
that's just none if you want to change
the color of none you can do that
classes commas dots functions operators
parameters functions probably the most
likely one because in the default theme
we it's colored black and that's
consistent with the rest of Visual
Studio which is why we went with that
but if you want to make that cyan you
can do that if you want the groupings to
all have grey backgrounds you can do
that if you want parameters to be white
on black you can do that and now you
have a headache yes
let's top stuff and I've done like this
thank you I'll pay you afterwards yeah
one thing you have to be yup spirit
so it's not so much type conversions the
biggest issue that you're face is is
interrupts between different language
runtimes
is the problem here so if you're working
in Windows forms you're sitting on top
of net if you're working in Python
you're sitting on top of C Python if
you're sitting on top of ironpython if
you want to go that route then you have
a much easier time except then you don't
get map lot Lib so as so it's probably
not the direction you want to go
every time I've I personally have wanted
to do UI with Python in the background
it's had to go through a sub process
effectively so I end up with a Python
script and we have a number of these
throughout the visual studio support
where there is just a Python script that
we we execute and we pass in some
parameters so if you're doing that I
would say you're probably making a
c-sharp app with the UI that you want
and part of that is going to call a
Python script and pass some parameters
wait for it to complete and then pick up
the results of disk you can do it
through memory it's it's easier to do it
of disk much much easier disk
there is some integration so I didn't
show it in the demo I'm over it
completely because I got distracted by
all the foot by all the the other cool
stuff when I came over to this window
you may notice those green buttons to
the right-hand side of every single info
Python environment those are going to
open an interactive window like I said
the whole idea of an integrated
environment is to take away all the
reasons you need to switch to another
place
all the reasons you need to old tab to
another window the aim is to take it
away and so we have interactive windows
built in these these are just
straight-up Python interactive windows
whatever you type it's going to execute
we just have pipe and running in the
background passing it back and forth if
you have a full numpy pandas matplotlib
set up a Python setup which I believe I
do here let me check so when you go to
your Python that has all the packages
installed ah no it's not this one no son
that one is it
nope have it somewhere
there we go so when you have one with a
Python matplotlib non pipe and as your
data stack that you work with we throw
in an extra option where for the
interactive window you can change the
mood so rather than being a standard
Python interactive window you can choose
to make it an eye Pathan based
interactive window it's not a drip of
the notebook don't don't have that image
in your mind that's not actually what
the mood is the mode enables ipython
interaction so when I start using this
now we're going to jump my numbers are
still pink oh I don't have a zmq okay
that's right I can fix that
so now have pay's mq and so I'm going to
jump into an I Python interactive for
those of us who have been using ipython
for longer than the than just the last
couple of years there's a there's a
console version which you use add a
prompt clearly a lot of people here have
been using it for longer than just the
last couple of years but there's there's
a lot of people who are just notebook
notebook notebook and now and now I'm in
this the the classic ipython prompt but
because we've enabled that mode we get
also we loop we get so the nice printing
that you wouldn't get in a regular a
Python a regular Python wrapper but
we've enabled plotting so we have you
can see the the signatures for things
popping up here as I use them and the
plots are going to appear in line as I
create them so if you're looking for
just this basic interaction for for the
repple thing and you're not you have
some stuff to do that doesn't require
jumping into a full notebook but you
still want to do it you want to be in
this interactive environment you want
the better intellisense
that we add you want the maybe you
really want your pink numbers you can
have them in in this interactive mode
but as a good segue and I think we're
running short on time but as a good
segue when you do want the full notebook
that is where you jump over to our Azure
machine learning so and from here this
is where you go into our preview service
which is new notebook and say I would
just like a notebook give me a notebook
and we'll give it to you and this like I
say this is in preview we're actively
developing this time is it on the west
coast actively developing it in about an
hour when because there's no one in the
office right now because it's 9 a.m.
but this I'm normally in there by now
but I'm over here Brett sniffing but we
are actively developing this it is what
we're hoping to make the the you know
the one of the the first really solid
enterprise-grade
Jupiter notebook services so and that
means everything along lines of sharing
collaboration security package
management that you need for being able
to run parts of a business on top of
this to be able to say hey my group
needs a new jupiter notebook for every
task they do go to this service and just
get it's like someone starts work and
they brought in their Windows laptop and
you're a Mac shop and you can't set them
up just yet
they have this service so they can just
go to and not worry about the platforms
question yeah the man who collects money
just left but I'm happy to pass most of
it on to him so yep but I don't actually
I don't actually remember the limits
that we put on this I think you're fine
for eight hours read what I think we get
in trouble for before you get in trouble
so this is a really good way to do it
so the caveats the caveats that are here
is you do need a a Microsoft account if
you want your notebooks to be saved so
it's that there's there's a sort of temp
ND mode where you don't need to login or
anything to get into it but after that
your time is up everything's just going
to disappear once you've logged in and
you don't have to pay anything just yet
it's it's a free like there's a free
tier for the service and there's no
limits on this but it will save
everything against your own account so
you know maybe you come back in a week
and we've killed the instance and you've
got to rerun everything but you haven't
lost the notebook yes
not yet not yet w so I'll answer the
first one first because it's more
disappointing yes and it doesn't work
very well I would not recommend it you
can debug a regular Python interactive
there's a few tricks involved that that
support was added very early on as hey
wouldn't it be cool if we could do this
let's do this
yeah it works and now no one's touched
it for a couple of years that's we're
actively looking and proving that for a
next release and that that's sort of a
big focus and being able to debug the
ipython kernel is also a big focus that
may not be achievable just because of
the amount of collaboration that's
involved in that and the amount of time
people physically have to to get
something like that going but but
debugging the interactive window does
work it can be a little confusing the
the last couple of times we've shown it
to someone and walk them through it
they've the the model is not what you
what it should be
and so it's not real clear the second
question being can you use the C++
debating on siphon I do so I've talked
to various different people I haven't
tried this recently
if siphon generates PDB files well
actually no because if the build process
generates PDB files that can be found so
probably it's going to be just your
tools fault if they can't be or set up
tools maybe which which is a safe you
know that's their safe we can blame
those no one's going to get upset but to
do that debugging we need the PDB files
which are generated by the compiler so
they will be generated they may be put
somewhere else and not be findable by
the debugger but I haven't tried that
recently depending on how siphon
generates the code it is possible to
have it map back into the siphon sauce
so that's a are you involved in the
siphon project no just interested if
anyone's involved in the siphon project
or watching on the video if you start
putting the line pragma everywhere you
have a line of siphon code the debugger
will map back to the original source
file instead of the generated c++ but it
relies on being able to find the
debugging databases the pdb files so it
is possible I don't think it's a very
smooth experience right now but that may
have changed recently yes I mean there's
this I I would I would love more people
to be following that because it means
they're working on the Python standard
library and everyone else was following
Pepe should be tweaking it to their own
needs
so having automatic Pepe right there is
not necessarily helpful personally I
find it annoying having having that so
the style impose automatically on me but
at the same time I can see the argument
for doing it and it also annoys me when
other people on my team don't use good
style and I would like to impose it so
so I can definitely see the arguments
for both sides of the Hat as far as
getting it individual studio it's a
prioritization concern we have such a
long list of things to do that one is
second half of the list and it's and and
just just so it's clear we we're
unlikely get through the first half of
the list because there is just so much
cool stuff that we're absolutely longing
to do all around data science we've got
great plans you may have noticed when I
was going through those lists of lists
of lists of numbers there's no table
view in there we're really like we're
committed to adding that and I think
giving people the choice of can I view
my matrix in an excel like grid or can I
have something complaining when I put a
space in the wrong spot people want the
grid I hope people want the grid
otherwise I really misjudged our user
base anything else yes
- to question human mouth fixing the
project the need to create a project
file in the next release guess how do
you envision and I guess the second in
terms of you mentioned the Python Visual
Studio bridge is actually the source of
extending that so so my the way I've
always envisioned like having the
directory based thing is basically what
sublime does or you know any of the
other editors say I'm in this directory
just showing me everything that's there
and then the trick for us is mapping
that into the internal models of because
we model the entire Python code and
we're modeling search paths model it
like we have an internal you know sister
path that we use for resolving things
and mapping from a project file where
users can easily override it when we
guess wrong is really convenient and as
soon as you take away the ability to
override that we have to be really
careful that we guess right because
otherwise people are just going to open
it and it says oh I can't import
anything because we guessed that you met
this directory and really you didn't and
there's no easy way for you to say oh no
I meant this one
so so I do envision it working like open
this directory showing me everything
that's here and then magic happens and
then everything works and we're still
working on the magic happens bit second
question was remind me how much how much
Python is it well ok so there's an easy
way to see github calm microsoft PT vs
is our site and you can see this big
green bar which lets you know that if
you're not a c-sharp developer there's
probably not a huge amount you can
contribute directly to the project that
said we have a number of important
pieces that are pure Python code a large
part of the debugger is pure Python so
that it's portable so a debugger will
work on all platforms we can remotely
attach to it from Windows to something
running on Mac or Linux and debug that
it will work in pipe a and Jason and
ironpython because it is just a pure
Python component
that can be easily contributed to well I
say that I'm not showing you the code
for it if you like refactoring messy
code bases then you can easily
contribute to the devote component of
Python tools for visual studio but it is
predominantly c-sharp that's that's why
you know a lot of our interests and the
contributions were encouraging from this
sort of audience is we'd love to have
really cool templates if there's stuff
that you just find yourself doing all
over anything hey other people would
like this we're happy to put that in
we're happy to credit like contributors
if you have code snippets that you just
use all the time and you know maybe you
get sick and bringing them forward every
time you update then we'd be happy to
look at those sorts of contributions
that's just an XML file it's not it's
not really difficult to write it's just
a lot of the sort of surrounding pieces
that plug into the core parts that are
written in c-sharp but it's an extension
on Visual Studio Visual Studio is
predominantly c-sharp C++ so anything
else it is a patchy - licensed as well
there's a CLA which is easy to sign but
it's Apache 2 license real easy to get
on board
if you come and post issues then you'll
get one of the team replying directly
probably me not if you do it today
I won't reply but it is it's a direct
line to the development team we don't
have no support staff there to you know
tell you to turn it off and back on
again before you actually get to speak
to someone who knows what to do it's its
director to the developers and we're
happy to help you get started if you
want to try and build and make changes
or whatever it is you're having trouble
with so I am completely out of time now
so thank you very much before I let you
go I do have two quick announcements to
make the first is well in fact they're
both after lunch and then after the
afternoon break there are birds of a
feather sessions going on the first of
those is 11:55 Bret canons going to be
hosting 155 I yeah he's here it's not a
very interesting and
why 155 Brett's hosting what is the
title of your forgotten Python 3 what is
it is it great or is it really great
yeah so so so that will be that so so
that will be in the bathroom which is
just around the corner at 1:55 and then
immediately after the break in the
afternoon I'll be hosting a buff on
Python on Windows so if you are a Python
user on Windows want to discuss anything
complain about things ask about things
I'll be there with hopefully someone to
shield me from the Rotten Tomatoes so
very much for coming happy to take more
questions offline but we're done thank
you